well the reason that they get away with
that is because Society has now labeled
obesity as healthy and with good reason
because Society remember all these media
outlets and this is where you get into
the Matrix but all of these media
outlets in large part are funded by
Pharma and what helps Pharma what helps
you to become somebody who's dependent
on medication for life and all the stuff
well you have to be unhealthy so now
this new like obesity is the new healthy
is being glorified by media because they
want an unhealthy population that's then
relying on Drugs That's relying on all
these things that's more likely to be
depressed that's more likely to be
someone who's not self-sufficient a
weaker society that you can control it's
all connected